[Music]
i'm broden and i own a business in
connecticut called the gutter guys today
i'm going to show you how to clean
gutters with wet and dry debris
[Music]
so when we clean a gutter with wet
debris nine times out of ten we want to
clean it by hand the reason why is when
it's wet it typically is very muddy and
there's a lot of what we call shingle
dust or
grit in the gutters and it's literally a
mud and when we blow them when they are
wet it makes a muddy mess all over the
house we want to clean them by hand for
that reason
so that is a gutter that is completely
jammed with leaves and debris
and the downspout was completely covered
when we released the debris out of the
downspout and got that gutter cleaned
all of that rain water that was in the
gutter just started to flow very heavily
right down the downspout as it should
so oftentimes when we do a gutter
cleaning not only do we find leaves but
we find plants so big that we actually
call them trees sometimes growing right
out of a gutter we're actually pulling
out a big plant and you can see the
whole root system come right out with it
certain types of trees give off these
little things that come off the tree and
will grow another tree and when those
land in the gutter it's a perfect
environment for that to grow
it's a classic sign that your gutters
have not been cleaned in years it also
puts a significant amount of weight from
the whole root system growing in the
gutter on the gutter which in turn will
pull that gutter off of the fascia board
which is actually the board behind the
gutter that the gutter is mounted to
wet debris is usually just saturated
with water water will overflow at the
gutter and get into your basement and
create cracks in your foundation once
water does find its way into your
basement it wreaks havoc
here the water that's flowing out of the
downspout at the bottom is the end
result that we are looking for so that
water will flow down and out as it
properly should
[Music]
when we see dry debris the reason why
that debris is dry is because there has
not been any rain in the past i would
say week or so so when we clean a gutter
that has dry debris oftentimes we will
use a hand blower and blow those gutters
out because it does a really good job of
just getting everything out of the
gutter whether it be leaves or sticks or
curly stuff that comes off in the spring
depending on the pitch of the roof we
will get on that roof start our hand
blower and walk across that roof line
hand blowing out all of the debris out
of that gutter
sometimes the debris is very compact and
it's thick that's a classic sign of
maybe a couple of years that somebody
had not had their gutters cleaned
we stick to one type of ladder and
that's an aluminum ladder the aluminum
ladder does conduct electricity so it's
very important we stay away from power
lines when we are moving aluminum
ladders we could get severely
electrocuted but certainly deadly which
is why we mark the power line areas with
flags before we start a gutter cleaning
because you're looking where you're
walking so you don't look up to see the
power lines so it's very important for
us to have a reminder that power lines
are there
we will often drop a penny down the
downspout just to know that that
downspout is free and clear because we
can see and hear it go all the way
through and back out at the bottom and
we know that we're in good shape
the best advice i can give a homeowner
is to be proactive and not reactive
typically when you're reactive it's too
late damage has been done the water may
already be in your basement it may
already be in your home and
it's just not a good way to maintain
your house water is
seriously detrimental to your house and
the main cause of water is from your
gutters so if you keep the gutters free
and clear
and you do consistent cleaning whether
it be two or three times per year which
we recommend you will never have any
issues with water in your basement or
ruining your flower beds or rotting out
the fascia and soffits of your home just
stay on top of gutter cleaning